ERIK DEMAINE: To me, the key
to teaching algorithms well
is just be excited
about the material.
I think if you personally think
these algorithms are really
cool and like, wow, how
did they come up with this,
and wow, I mean, look how this
thing interacts with this thing
and magically it
all runs super fast,
I think communicating
that excitement,
students pick up on
it really quickly
and themselves get engaged in
the material and care-- care
more about it.
So I just try to have
fun with the material
and encourage the students to
similarly have fun learning it.
So it all comes together.
Occasionally, we'll
do a demonstration.
But a lot of the
material in this class
is pretty theoretical.
So it's mostly board
work and trying
to draw representative
figures and things like that.